>>> FLORIDA'S LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS REVERSING A DECISION
ON HOW TO TEACH SEX ED TO
MIDDLE
SCHOOLERS AND HIGH SCHOOLERS.
THE SCHOOL BOARD HAD APPROVED
THIS TEXTBOOK YOU SEE ON THE
SCREEN IN APRIL BUT REVERSED THE
DECISION LAST WEEK AFTER SOME
PARENTS COMPLAINED.
THE PARENTS' CITED FLORIDA'S
STATE LAW THAT ALLOW PARENTS
MUCH MORE SAY IN THE CURRICULUM.
LUISA SANTOS IS A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER WITH MIAMI-DADE COUNTY
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT, AT THIS
SCHOOL BOARD MEETING LAST WEEK,
THERE WERE 38 PARENTS AND
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WHO CAME OUT IN SUPPORT OF THIS
CURRICULUM, THE SEX ED AND THIS
TEXTBOOK BUT THERE WERE FOUR
PEOPLE WHO SPOKE AGAINST IT.
SO WHY DID THE SCHOOL BOARD SIDE
WITH THE VERY SMALL MINORITY?
>> ALISYN, THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION.
I DID NOT SIDE WITH THE SMALL
MINORITY BECAUSE I KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS EDUCATION AND
I REPRESENT PARENTS AND PARENTS
CAME TO TELL US THAT.
STUDENTS CAME TO TELL US THAT
THEY NEEDED THIS.
BUT WE ALSO HAD A PROCESS THAT
THANKS TO THIS NEW LAW THAT IS
IN PLACE, PARENTS OBJECTED TO
THE CURRICULUM.
AND I AM ALL FOR PARENT CHOICE,
PARENT TRANSPARENCY, PARENTS
SHOULD BE OUR PARTNERS IN
EDUCATION, AND PARENTS OF THE
278 PETITIONS THAT WERE FILED
AGAINST THIS TEXTBOOK, ONLY 44
WERE FROM PARENTS OF STUDENTS IN
OUR SCHOOLS, AND AT THE HEARING,
WHERE THEY COULD COME AND VOICE
THEIR CONCERNS, ONLY FOUR CAME,
AND ONLY THREE SPOKE.
SO UNFORTUNATELY, WITH, YOU
KNOW, A SCHOOL DISTRICT OF
340,000 STUDENTS AND LESS THAN
1% OF PEOPLE COMING TO SAY
ANYTHING AGAINST THIS TEXTBOOK,
WE FIND OURSELVES WITH NO HEALTH
EDUCATION FOR ANY STUDENT.
>> SO LET'S LOOK AT SOME OF THE,
YOU KNOW, OBJECTIONABLE CONTENT
TO THIS MINORITY OF PEOPLE OR
PARENTS.
BASICALLY HERE'S THE TEXTBOOK
FOR MIDDLE SCHOOLERS, OKAY, SO
6th THROUGH 8th GRADERS, AND ONE
OF THE PASSAGES IS ABOUT BIRTH
CONTROL.
AND IT SAYS EVEN WHEN PARTNERS
AGREE TO USE BIRTH CONTROL AND
TRY TO USE IT CORRECTLY,
MISTAKES CAN HAPPEN.
IN THESE CASES A PERSON MIGHT
USE EMERGENCY CONTRACEPTION TO
HELP PREVENT PREGNANCY.
SEVERAL TYPES OF EMERGENCY
CONTRACEPTION PILLS ARE
AVAILABLE OVER THE COUNTER AND
DO NOT REQUIRE PRESCRIPTIONS,
INCLUDING ELLA AND PLAN B ONE
STEP.
BY THE WAY, THE SOURCE OF THIS
IS THE CONSERVATIVE GROUP THAT
OBJECTS TO THE TEXTBOOK.
WE'RE TAKING THEM AT THEIR WORD
THIS IS WHAT'S IN THE TEXTBOOK
AND WHAT THEY OBJECT TO.
LET'S TAKE THEIR SIDE, DO YOU
NEED TO TELL 6th THROUGH 8th
GRADERS WHAT THE EMERGENCY
CONTRACEPTION IS AND HOW TO GET
IT.
>> THAT IS CORRECT, AND THAT IS
WHAT IS IN THE TEXTBOOK.
IF A PARENT DOES NOT WANT THEIR
CHILD TO KNOW THAT, THEY HAVE
AND WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
OPTION TO OPT OUT OF THIS
PORTION OF STUDY, SO IF YOU
DON'T WANT YOUR CHILDREN TO
TOUCH THAT, THAT IS TOTALLY
FINE.
YOU ALWAYS HAVE THE RIGHT TO OPT
OUT.
BUT IF YOU DO WANT TO LEARN
ABOUT THIS, THEN YOUR CHILD
SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO
THAT, NOT BECAUSE SOME MINORITY
SAID THEY SHOULDN'T, AND THIS
INFORMATION IS CRUCIAL.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, WE KNOW ARE
FROM ALL THE RESEARCH AND ALL
THE STUDIES THAT ABOUT 40% OF
STUDENTS WILL HAVE SEXUAL
INTERCOURSE OF SOME SORT BEFORE
THEY GRADUATE, AND IT IS OUR JOB
TO GIVE THEM THE INFORMATION TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND TO MAKE
RESPONSIBLE AND HEALTHY
DECISIONS!
BUT, I MEAN, YOU'RE SAYING
BEFORE THEY GRADUATE HIGH
SCHOOL, NOT BEFORE THEY GRADUATE
GRAMMAR SCHOOL.
THIS ONE WAS FOR MIDDLE SCHOOL.
BUT EITHER WAY, LET ME TELL YOU
WHAT ONE OF THE PARENTS WHO
SPOKE AGAINST THE CURRICULUM
SAID ABOUT THE OPT OUT OPTION.
HERE SHE IS.
>> THE OPT OUT FORMS ARE NOT
CLEAR TO US PARENTS.
THEY DO NOT SPECIFY THE
SENSITIVE TOPICS AT HAND THAT
YOU INTEND ON TEACHING OUR
CHILDREN, ABORTION, GENDER
IDEOLOGY.
YOU SHOULD NOT BE SAYING PARENTS
HAVE INFORMED CONCEPT BY FILLING
OUT AN OPT OUT FORM, SO THEY
KNOW WHAT IS IN THE TEXT BOOKS.
>> BASICALLY SHE'S SAYING SHE
COULDN'T GET THE INFORMATION SHE
WANTED.
IS THAT FAIR?
>> THAT'S COMPLETELY UNFAIR.
BECAUSE OF THE LAW WHICH WE
FOLLOWED TO THE T, WE POST EVERY
SINGLE CHAPTER OF THIS ON OUR
HOME PAGE.
WHEN YOU GO TO THE 4th LARGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE NATION,
DADESCHOOLS.NET, THROUGHOUT THE
REVIEW PROCESS, THE FIRST THING
YOU SAW WAS INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS AND YOU COULD GO THERE
AND SEE IT.
WE ADVERTISE $12,000 IN AD BUYS
IN LOCAL NEWSPAPERS, TV
STATIONS, TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
SINGLE PERSON WHO WANTS TO COULD
COME AND SPEAK TO US, AND THEY
DID.
AND WE DID HEAR FROM MANY
PEOPLE.
AND THEY HAVE AN OPTION TO OPT
OUT.
EVERY PARENT GETS A LETTER WHEN
THIS UNIT OF STUDY IS GOING TO
START TO BE TAUGHT.
AND THEY HAVE TO SIGN TO SAY,
YES, I WANT THIS, AND NOW THEY
CAN SEE EXACTLY LINE BY LINE,
WHAT THE CHAPTER MAY INCLUDE,
WHAT THE TEACHER MAY TALK ABOUT.
AND SO I DON'T FEEL LIKE THAT'S
A FAIR STATEMENT AT ALL.
>> OF ALL OF THIS, THAT THERE
WILL BE NO SEX ED IN THE LARGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN FLORIDA THIS
COMING YEAR?
>> ALISYN, SAY THE FIRST PART
AGAIN.
>> WILL THERE NOT BE SEX ED THIS
YEAR FOR MIAMI-DADE STUDENTS?
>> UNFORTUNATELY, THIS DOES MEAN
THAT STARTING NEXT SCHOOL YEAR,
UNTIL WE GO THROUGH THIS WHOLE
ADOPTION PROCESS AGAIN, THERE
WILL -- THIS CLASS CANNOT BE
TAUGHT BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
APPROVED MATERIALS TO DO THAT.
SO BECAUSE OF A SMALL GROUP THAT
HAD THE OPTION TO OPT OUT AND
THE VOTES THE WAY THEY LANDED,
NOBODY WILL HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
UNTIL WE